[Music]
how many of you have watch a movie the
Martian it's a pretty cool movie isn't
it some of you may remember that the
China National Space Administration had
developed some rockets to launch an
unmanned exploration proper that rocket
could be used to send additional
supplies to keep Matt Damon alive that
rocket was the only one that could be
used in time and NASA didn't know it
existed
the Chinese scientists eventually
approach NASA and a true science agency
Richard Hill long story short Matt Damon
is happily back to earth thanks to a
cooperation between NASA and China I
think the story illustrates a dream of
cooperation between the two countries in
a territory of enormous uncertainty it
is a mission that wouldn't have been
possible with other facilitation of
scientists in the US and China it is
also a story and movie that the Chinese
people really love as they ponder the
more prominent role of China in the 21st
century as we discuss AGI I would like
us to keep this narrative in mind that
China might be developing some rockets
to get you AGI and some of those rocket
could be really critical for our world
collective safety and governance
endeavors the mission of building safe
and beneficial AGI needs to be a joint
worldwide effort with China my key
concern with AGI is best captured in the
open air charter it describes a
collective action problem where the
late-stage
AGI development might become a
competitive race without time for safety
precautions and since a judge how much
remain highly uncertain we should take
into account the emerging projects of
tomorrow and not just the leading ones
today and that's how China comes into
the picture and here I would like to
catch all the specific kinds of
understanding they are the most
important we got in China to have solid
and robust global coordination I believe
having the following share hypotheses is
very important first there is a serious
possibility that AGI could be developed
in the coming decades
second as AGI becomes to follow
there are enormous uncertainties and
risk with such energy third
International Cooperation AI is not a
zero-sum game it could be merely truly
beneficial for both countries as they
share a common course in how a is
developed and deployed country my face
cooperative incentives in both
minimizing the downside risk as well as
capturing the enormous upside potential
the AGI has so in the rest of my
presentation I'm going to give you the
Chinese perspective on the following
hypotheses then I would suggest a few
approaches that could foster greater
coordination with China finally I'll
wrap up by suggesting how you might be
able to help in China it seems that the
idea of AGI is gradually emerging into
the public discourse as evidenced by
discussions in the academia policymaking
and expert interviews Kuantan Joon who
is here today is the chair of computer
science at Peking University he was also
a key chapter of the China's AIT fluent
plan he has made multiple statements
that strong AI may appear in the next 15
to 30 years tan Tien o who is the deputy
general of Chinese Academy of Sciences
he was giving a lecture to the top
legislative body in China the National
People's Standing Committee there he was
discussing the future trends of AI and
the first point he notes is a
development from narrow to general AI
citing the goal of deep mind and a quote
from demis hassabis in 2017 there was
this expert in the view and survey on AR
timelines and he found that respondents
who receive undergraduate education in
China predicted that there are 28 years
before the arrival of human machine
intelligence as compared to 76 years for
those who study in the US as a median
estimate if you find out that private a
LF in China an interest in such research
it seems reasonable to infer that they
believe such technology is possible in
the coming few decades of course
companies in China just like everywhere
else have numerous motivations for
expressing one's interest in AGI such as
attracting top talent
or you know premium prestige but that
said it still seems useful to you know
which labs are claiming to be heading in
that direction and here's some examples
Qi way who was the prominent scientist
at by to entity of deep learning
co-founded by Andrew hang at a time
belief that we should stop talking about
whether Asia is peaceful and begin
coming up with concrete ways to develop
such technology and now he has moved on
to the southern horizon robotics as the
chief sciences of general air lab that
lab has explicit long term goal of
deploying human level general AI yeah
saying who is the vice president
attention has made multiple statements
that developing AGI is one of three
strategic priorities for the company in
particular he believes that games are
the most important direction
40:14 AGI because all the world's
leading AI research companies are
heading in that direction and let's look
at their research into that in for a
moment
it may choose an eighteen they develop
in Xcode based on half ago zeros
published paper and then later applied
Monte Carlo tree search techniques to
their own game King of glory which is a
complex multiplayer mobile game in China
then in September they developed T star
put their own product to beat the signal
level Pai in Sacre - and just in last
month they published the paper
hierarchical macros use MicroStrategy
model and apply it to the game of Gouri
and in particular 5v5 instead of 1v1 so
the game becomes a lot more complex and
they claim that they are now competitive
with the top 1% of human players so with
JD calm which is the Amazon of China the
director of a lab also has made a public
lecture talking about the seven key
technical challenges of developing AGI
he gives examples such as advances in a
technique of unsupervised learning and
learning to learn now I assume some
evidence that China thinks that AGI
might be a plausible technology in the
upcoming few decades and many of the
Chinese
thinkers have also public
express the concerns with the risk of
such analogy one of them is told you
have who has written the undergraduate
textbook in machine learning in China in
some way this rustle in the country he
has published said that strong AI should
not I cannot be done and suggest that no
AI researchers should develop such
energy as email it to the greater
survival crisis for Humanity another
person is dojo ha who is one of the most
influential living philosophers in China
has written a long essay arguing that we
should set the safety conditions for AI
as super intelligence my literate
earthshaking and to human history jung
ji who is a deputy director at research
center for bringing in spirit
intelligence and who is here today as
well has taught a class on philosophy
and ethics of AI in the course at the
university of chinese academy of
sciences he discusses the problem of
existential risk of AI to assess the
intention of China one of the best way
is to look at what the political leaders
say given the importance of top-down and
elite political communication in
mobilizing the effort of the whole
society at the world air conference in
Shanghai last year a statement resurect
for president xi jinping
the statement emphasized that china is
willing to cooperate with other
countries to promote development improve
security and share result in AI in
particular China is particularly
interested in issues such as legislation
governance ethics and security of AI lü
ha is a China USA war chief as people
call it him I felt and surprisingly
nationalistic in 2000 but he still echo
Presidency's view by saying that AI
represents a new era in which cross
national cooperation is inevitable so
more generally I think that there are
few short term challenges and long term
opportunities in fostering greater
coordination on AI safety with China
currently I think that there is some
confusion was the idea of a SCV partly
because the terms si VA s security are
the same in Mandarin Antron we later
there is relatively little awareness of
alignment research for AGI second it
seems to me that some of the Chinese
thinkers have hopefully focused on the
topic of consciousness as compared to
just thinking about the risk of a
generally competent goal-oriented system
which might not be conscious but
nevertheless roaring our concerns in the
longer term however I am optimistic of
China being a responsible actor in
developing and deploying the technology
the first reason is that China is run as
a technocracy with most proven leaders
being educated as engineers and
scientists for their school and in one
of the recent interview with Joe Rogan
Elon Musk has said that politicians in
China a pretty good at science he met
with the mayor of Beijing who holds a
PhD degree in environmental engineering
and the mayor of Shanghai whom Ilan
described as very smart so given the
technical complexity of AGI it seems
beneficial that a government and its
politicians understand signs of a
technology second the China model allows
the country to engage in long term
planning which lets you project such as
the national rail system through the
five-year planning and the Hofstede
cultural theory also suggests that the
Chinese rank extremely highly on the
dimension of long term orientation this
means that they have a tendency to you
know focus on longer term results
instead of the short term goals
certainly China has a historical view of
dynastic cycles with dozens of dynasties
having rising and falling in the past
four thousand years and this means that
the prospect of a civilizational
collapse is deep-rooted in China's
subconscious and this makes
risk-management
one of the key topics in governance for
China so given all these factors it
seems that China might be able to be a
responsible actor in developing and
deploying transformative AI and this
gives a window opportunity for fostering
coordination in AI safety so given these
contexts I'm going to talk a little bit
about some of the promising approaches
for strengthening coordination with
China
given my research at the Center for the
governance of AI so the first approach
is to establish collaboration with
técnicos a ICT so in a recent paper
published by a covenant I don't feel as
the think-tank it suggests that we have
enormous issues with problems such as
robustness in distributional shift
interoperability and explicitly cited
the Congress of safety
it suggests that China should begin
international cooperation in a ICT
research while promoting the deployment
from narrow to general AI in particular
China should set up overseas research
centers and begin international tenable
exchange between researchers as some of
the concrete policy ideas here I also
compiled a list of research focus
international partnerships and found
that six out of seven of them or
industry-university collaboration so one
example is the collaboration between MIT
and since time the second approach is to
support the multi-stakeholder and
Industry Alliance effort from China and
internationally I see the participation
of bite you in panel AI as a positive
development as you was the first Chinese
member to do so organizations should
continue to invest in such effort and I
think certain working groups API might
be more technically oriented and easier
to reach global consensus such as the
safety critical AI group on the other
hand organization could consider you
know interfacing with China let
alliances one example is a China AI
industry alliance with members such as
Microsoft and IBM more recently there
was also this global AI academic
alliance which was founded by 50 members
with the majority of them being Chinese
institutions but also a few universities
such as University of Sydney and MIT the
third approach is to foster the machine
learning AI transnational epistemic
community so epistemic community are
networks of experts with policy relevant
and authoritative
expertise and this form of governance
has contributed to the creation of not
nuclear non-proliferation policy as a
example I think the case for optimism in
ml is strong because you know
almost
all the researchers from around the
world attend the same conferences and
according to a study a quarter of the
co-authors at 2017 triple-a I conference
were Chinese and the conference was even
rescheduled due to a original conflict
with Chinese New Year another report
suggests that 53% of top papers from
China involve international
collaboration and the network graph here
shows that china is most connected with
researchers in the US Canada and
Australia the fourth approach is to
bridge the Western and Chinese air
ethical principles so in 2018 the first
three eight the co-principals came out
of China represented by efforts at
Chinese Academy of Sciences 10 Central
Research energy and by June all these
principles include consideration of
safety frequently with the phrase safe
and reliable untrained cow notably the
one by ten senators in the to include a
precautionary principle suggesting that
we should ensure HDI serve the interest
of humanity as suggested in the linking
ID principles project here it shows that
almost all the international proposals
of ethical principles include
consideration of safety so this can
hopefully be a shared basis for
constructive global dialogue between
China and the rest of the world now with
these context and approaches I'm going
to talk about some of the implications
for people in this room and how you can
help I think a primary approach is to
support the local development of safe
and reliable AI in in China and foreign
authorisation individuals can play
important role of being a technical
adviser in different capacities so one
way to do it is that you can work with a
local Chinese partner in you know during
our projects in the country for example
procuring energy panel was peaking
University in launching the China Center
and have engaged with people like
Francesca Rossi in pass a Icicle
discussion events the second thing that
you can do is to invite Chinese
researcher to attend conferences like
this one and allow you know
cross-cultural dialogue to happen at
these conferences and on
a very important topic of of AI safety
the first thing is that you can be a
technical adviser a speaker or a
participant at some of the AI tenneco
safety workshops hosted by Chinese
intrusions X example that I'm really
excited about
Ching hua university instead of AI is
planning to organize an international
conference on AI safety and it is the
top AI academic lab in China so it could
really be a good bridge for developing
global next practices in air safety and
be local champion of this course in
China in general I am building a team to
facilitate the coordination between
Chinese and foreign organizations in the
topic of safety and governance so I
really love to talk if you're interested
in supporting advising or getting
involved in any capacity going forward I
think that more people should do
research and participate in the
discussions of global coordination
involving China so there are many topics
that you know people could contribute to
for example in research it seems that
there is a predominant paradigm of the
approach of bringing inspire
intelligence or even bring light
intelligence for AJ researchers in China
and one question would be what are the
safety and coordination implications for
this in policy are there any common
policy concerns between you know US
government industry Chinese government
Chinese industry and how could we
imagine and conceptualize HR to dialogue
in a safety in the future in terms of
kind of normative destinations or I do
confidence using the terminology by
Ellen can we find commonalities between
Chinese and Western thoughts on global
governance theories in China there are
discussions on 10 SIA or under heaven as
a as a theory of global governance and
also the community of shared future for
mankind from the government and last I
would just let you emphasize that global
coordination a scale doesn't occur
effortlessly in 1975 the isothermal
conference on recombinant DNA was
organized by 140 mostly Western
scientists and that meant researchers
from other countries had to contend with
throughs that they had no role in
establishing for decades later in 2015
many
the scientists recognized need to have
buy-in from China and they wanted to
organize a crisper ethical conferences
involving Chinese researchers and so the
conference was colonized with Chinese
Academy of Sciences and in 2018 the
second conference was even hosted in
Hong Kong
instead of Washington DC in AI we likely
to not have four decades to get this
coordination right and the prospect of
the world would be much brighter if we
can have more talented Chinese
contributing to a SAV research agenda
and also the dialogue of global
governance and as the Chinese often say
the whole world within the four seas
belong to one family so I really look
forward to building this global future
of share HDI with all of you thank you
we've got time for a few questions
thanks very much for a great talk I
think you've given us a lot of great and
interesting reasons to have optimism
about the future of cooperation but not
to be overly pessimistic what do you
think could go wrong like what are the
main things that you think could cause
cooperation to fail yeah I think there
are a lot of nuances in communicating
the potential risks and benefits of AI
even though we would want to have
greater coordination and we love to
believe that there are you know enormous
with distributable gains from from safe
AI there is also game theoretic
situations where it might make sense to
really fast forward the development so I
would be very cautious about
communicating idea of hgi when I
interface was with organizations and try
to frame and discuss all the nuances of
such idea and I think that this problem
my accessory bait might be exacerbated
from you know the media talking about
arms race narrative in most of the time
so I think within this committee you
will be useful to you know to combat
this narrative of you know it is always
a zero-sum game and it is always ever
Sariel and I think we need to do this
very carefully and and diligently
thanks very much Brian now that was
great this is not so much a question but
just following up on this I know it's
really really short notice because it's
come up very quickly if anybody is
passing through Hong Kong later this
week January 11th and 12th
we are gonna at HHA USD in Hong Kong
post the first time fat ml in Asia to
try to promote more of this dialogue
across the cultures this is a trial you
can drop by there a lot of tutorials to
get local communities up to speed
and then there will be a real bigger one
later on in this year around November
and then wouldn't we very much welcome
partnering with anybody who has ideas
thank you very much was a great talk I
was interested in the fact that you the
linguistic conflation between security
and safety I wonder if there are
insights to be had in translation of
words like generality agency
consciousness and do Chinese researchers
come at any of these problems from
different directions because of those
differences in in linguistics that's a
interesting question
I haven't thought too much about it and
I don't have a good example yeah I think
I think a lot of the terms in AI and
machine learning have been translated
from English so reinforcement learning
for instance is basically a direct
translation from language but in terms
of you know concepts such as
consciousness that might be different
but I have to think more about that and
get back to you
okay good so um in the US and in Europe
oftentimes when we talk about governance
concerns there's this ongoing tension
about whether we should be talking more
about near-term concerns initially in
getting some definitions down or whether
we should be talking about AGI and and
future prospects and I guess what I'm
you know I understand this conference is
specifically about AGI and therefore
your presentation underscored that but
what I don't understand about China yet
is what's a better way of approaching
these governance concerns with China is
it through the AGI issue or are these
questions of responsibility in privacy
and you know the the wrath of other
near-term concerns is is that really
getting on the governance table or is
that still sort of in the discussion
period yeah I think the boundary between
near term and longer term might not be
as distinct as people usually make out
so I think with examples such as
interpretability it is both a technical
problem that is important for the
near-term in the longer term and I think
that a lot of a few researchers believe
that there are insights you behalf from
from you know current efforts and that
could be applied to advanced AI system
so I think just engaging with Chinese
researchers on the topic of ASAP doesn't
really assume that we need to talk about
AGI and I think there are revenues
avenues of cooperation even even in that
light that's said I think you know in
terms of a policy it might make sense
you have more explicit boundary of you
know what is the timeframe that we're
talking about and I think that I would
be interested in exploring what kind of
policy concerns that you know Chinese
government industry and the US
government industry both have as I as I
alumina as I suggested in the
presentation and that might be you know
safety critical AI that might be you
know malicious news from terrorists and
others and and you know currently China
and US are already building a lot of
cooperation on on counterterrorism so I
think that there are these kind of
leverage points to bill corpora
and hopefully you know as we go for it
with more transform the AI people
already sitting in the same room and
talking to each other for for for quite
a while let's think buying a gun for a
great talk
[Applause]
[Music]